Now let's recap RSA and see how things fit together.
We have our modulus n, which is the product of 2 primes.
We have our encryption function, which raises m to the e power,
and we have our decryption function, which raise the ciphertext to the d power.
For the invertibility property, we need to know that m^(ed - 1) = 1 mod n.
What we know from Euler is that that's true for a and n relatively prime.
That means if we can pick e and d such that ed - 1 is equal to φ(n),
then we're real close to having the correctness property we need.
To see how close we are, let's ask a quiz
whether we can determine if m and n are relatively prime.
That's the property we need to be able to use Euler's theorem.